this is nothing short of a virtual
invasion by the russians
into critical accounts of our federal
government we need to make it clear
to mr putin to china to iran to north
korea
and to any nation that would compromise
and breach our security
that there is a price to pay no i'm not
calling for an invasion myself
or all-out war i don't want to see that
happen but it's no longer a buddy-buddy
arrangement between the united states
and vladimir putin
the cyber attack this hack is expansive
it is likely still ongoing according to
senior intelligence officials we don't
know the extent of it we know it's
touched
a number of government agencies there is
a statement
from the just came out from the senate
armed services committee
chairman and ranking member the cyber
intrusion appears to be ongoing
has the hallmarks of a russian
intelligence operation the u.s
government must do everything possible
to counter it
one of the immediate steps the
administration can take to improve
up improve our cyber posture is signing
the ndaa
into law that's the national defense
authorization act is always
must pass legislation but this cyber
incident makes it even more
urgent that the bill become law without
further delay this of course after
president trump threatened to veto that
bill because it didn't include
some pushback what section 230 on the
social media companies the platforms
that's just one element of this but it
is expansive let's bring in our panel mo
alethe executive director of the
georgetown institute
of politics susan fercio chief
congressional correspondent washington
examiner
and bill mcgiren columnist for the wall
street journal bill um
you know it's scary to hear some of
these officials on capitol hill saying
they haven't been fully briefed yet we
obviously have not heard
president trump speak out about this
intrusion
but everything we're hearing is that
it's touching a lot of government
and also private sector
yeah i think look the nature of this is
once you get in
you unlock one door the other doors
become
a lot easier to open and look it's not
the first time
you know what five years ago i found out
that my personal information
was in beijing's hands because of a hack
then
of a database of former federal
employees and i had worked for the bush
administration
we've had iranian hacks and we've had
north korean acts
so it's an ongoing it's an ongoing
problem and for all we spend
on defense we don't seem to be doing a
good job of protecting some of our most
vital information
senator mitt romney mo just tweeted out
a couple of hours ago
this the cyber hack is like russian
bombers have been repeatedly flying
undetected over our entire country
alarming u.s vulnerability apparent
cyber warfare weakness
glaring inadequate cyber defenses in
inexcusable silence and inaction
from the white house past time for a
national security reset
that prioritizes cyber security
capabilities and defenses
thoughts yeah in the year where um
there hasn't been a lot of
bipartisanship in this town i do
think that this is one of those issues
where you are starting to see democrats
and republicans
understand the severity of the situation
and and sort of rallying behind some
action
increasing uh frustration that we're not
hearing a robust response from the white
house
increased bipartisan calls for
the president to put aside this this
silly notion of not
funding uh not not signing the defense
bill
at a time when we really need the
defense bill to fight this sort of
thing and i completely agree with
with bill's point that you know
we're not we're spending a lot of money
in that defense bill maybe it's time for
us to reevaluate how we spend that money
and devote a little bit more of it to
cyber security
but look the new administration is going
to have a lot that it needs to get done
on this given how much the current
administration has hollowed out
our cyber security defenses you
mentioned the bipartisan
nature of this there here are two
republicans uh senators
kramer and scott speaking on this
it would be nice not only to get a
briefing out but then of course know
what safeguards are in place and why we
should be confident it will never happen
again if russia is going to do these
type of things
uh against our system and then we ought
to be very aggressive to make sure
that one they get no benefit out of it
and actually they're harmed out of it we
if you you can't let's sit here and just
say oh please
don't do it again you've got to say okay
so what are we going to do to make sure
they suffer
consequences and susan i guess the
question is
you know as i mentioned we have not
heard from president trump
or key administration officials yet
publicly
but we have heard from capitol hill well
remember back in 2015
this seems to happen regularly a foreign
government hacking our government
the chinese hacking of the office of
personal management
22 million data breaches for employees
including like every single person who
got a security clearance
and months went by and obama did not
president obama did not react to it
no sanctions no response they couldn't
figure out what to do
because they didn't want to expose our
own intelligence gathering that we're
conducting on china this is a
complicated issue
and clearly the the congress and the
administrations
have never come up with a good solution
for it because it keeps
happening the good news is this past
election russian interference was kept
at bay
after some ramped up efforts and extra
money put into the
into this whole process i think what
you're going to see now is
set defense cyber security front and
center in the next defense funding
measures
any any upcoming spending bill beyond
this year this is going to be a very
important issue and it's not going away
because this is probably one of the
biggest breaches and most dangerous
breaches we've seen so far
and i guess what we don't really are
trying what we're trying to gauge
is the threat from china the threat from
russia here's senator tom cotton
analyzing both of those things today
china aims to replace the united states
as the world superpower they don't have
the know-how they don't have the
technical ability
they don't have the people and our the
brilliance of our researchers and our
scientists to do that on their own
that's why
they hack into our universities our
laboratories our businesses to try to
steal our technology
russia tends to hack into uh systems to
then release the information using it
for propaganda or for misinformation
purposes
but bill i mean bottom line is that both
can be a threat to us
yeah they're they're all threats to us
in my mind and look this is a
particularly vulnerable area none of us
are cyber experts
but you know security always depends on
the weak link you know snowden was a
contractor
and managed to download all this
information i was just reading before
this
you know the chinese built the great
wall and had the manchus get in they
bribed the guards at the gate
there's always human errors people use
passwords that are their birthday
um and we we need to double our efforts
to try to make them more secure and look
for those things i agree with mo in the
sense
i'm not just for throwing a lot of money
at this i think we we need to take a
look at how we spend our money
and are we getting the bang for the buck
here
yeah and don't use the word password for
your password
all right panel stand by